Now that we understand the high level
goal of GMS, the most important parameter in
the working of GMS system is age managemet because we need to identify what is
the globally oldest page whenever want to
do replacements And let's see how that algorithm
works and how it is managed. So in any distributed system, one of the goals
is to make sure that any management
work is not bringing down the productivity of
that node. In other words, you want
to make sure that Management work is distributed
and not concentrated on any one node and you know in the GMS system, since we
are working with an active set of nodes. Overtime, the node that is active,
may become inactive and a node that was inactive
may become and so on. And so you don't
want the management of age information to be assigned
to any given node. But it is something that
has to shift over time. And that's sort of
the fundamental tenant of building any distributed system. Is
to make sure that we distribute the management work
so that no single node in the distributed system
is overburdened of that. That's a general principle,
and we'll see how that principle is followed in
this particular system. So we break the management.
Both along the space axis and time axis, into
what is called epochs, and there are two
parameters that govern an epoch. One is T, which
is the maximum duration of an epoch. That
is, an epoch is in some sense a granularity.
Of management work done by a node. And that management work done by a node
is either time bound, maximum T duration, or
space bound, maximum M replacements. So if, in
the working of the system, if M
space replacements. Have happened, then that epoch is
complete, so we go to a new epoch. There'll be a new manager for age management.
Or if the duration T is complete, then
again, the epoch is complete, and so we pick
a new manager to manage the next epoch. And
we'll see in a minute how we pick the
new manager. And T maybe on the order of a few seconds. And M, which is the
number of replacements, maybe on the order of thousands
of replacements. So at the start of each epoch
what happens is every node is going to send
the age information to the initiator. That is.
Every node is going to say, what is the
age of the pages that is resident at this
node. All the local pages, all the global
pages, universe of all the pages that exist
at this node, what is the age information
associated with that? And remember that the smaller the
age, the more relevant the page is. So the
higher the age, the older the page. So, in
picking a candidate, we're always going to pick an
old page to replace. So, that's the age information that
each of these node ascending to the initiator. So,
in one sense. Its set of pages, N2 sends
its set of pages, and so on. Everybody is
sending to the manager node that I'm calling the initiator,
the age information. What the initiator node is going to
do is two things. It's going to find out what
is the minimum age of all the M pages
that are going to be replaced. Remember that. Smaller
the age, the better. So what it is going to
say is out of all the pages that exist
in the entire cluster, what are the oldest M
pages that are going to be replaced in the upcoming
epoch, and for those M old pages, out of those M old pages, what is the minimum
age? So any page with less than the minimum
age are pages that are active and that are
going to survive this upcoming epoch. Whereas, any page whose
age is older than that minimum age, is part
of this set of M pages that are going to
be replaced in the upcoming epoch, and those are
the replacement candidates. That's minimum age. So
it computes the minimum age. And it also
computes given the minimum age and given the
distribution of the age demographics coming from N1,
I know out of these pages coming from N1 what fraction of the pages that belong
to N1 are going to be replaced in the
upcoming epoch. And that is the weight parameter
for this particular node. For instance, if it turns out that N1 has 10% of the
candidate pages that are going to be replaced
in the next epoch, then its wage is 0.1.
If N2 is going to account for 30% of
the replacements 30% of the M replacements in the
upcoming epoch. Then N2's weight is going to be
W2 and so on. So what this initiative does
is it computes this min age and it also
computes the weight for each one of the nodes,
and that's what is sent back to each node.
So each node is going to see the min age and
also the weight for all [UNKNOWN]. Each load is
not only receiving its own weight, that is its
own fraction of the [INAUDIBLE] pages that are going
to be replaced, but it is also getting the fraction
of the pages that are going to be replaced from
each of its peer nodes in the entire cluster. And
we'll see how this information is going to be used
by each one of these nodes. And of course, we
don't know the future, all that the initiator is doing.
Is that is saying that it is expected replacement. W1
is expected share of replacement that's going to happen in N1.
W2 is expected share of replacement that's going to happen in
N2 and so on. And when the next epoch
starts actually. That can be different, depending on what
happens in these [INAUDIBLE]. But, that's the best that
we can do is use the past to predict the
future. That's what the initiates doing. It is using
the past, the age information that it got from all
the notes, in order to predict the future in
terms of where these end replacements are going to happen.
What is the minimum age of the pages that are going to be
replaced in the next epoch. So that's what is being done by the initiator.